I think the the biggest thing is that we
have this new banking system that is not
not your father's banking system and we
we have an idea of what a bank is a bank
is a big marble building with a sign in
the window that says FDIC insured right
and and you go in and do you get cash or
you deposit cash and those things still
exist
we're like shopping mall store for
instant big marble buildings but they
still are ordinary banks but at this
point where most of what at least on the
eve of the crisis most of the banking
activity was going on in this economy
was things that didn't look like that
they were things that actually had no no
storefront certainly no no no big marble
building there were things like
asset-backed commercial paper funds or
money market funds or auction rate
securities all of these institutions
that were for you know what they were
giving people what they thought was a
way to park their cash with ready access
to it but they were paying higher
interest rates than banks paid and in
return they were they were then lending
that money out and it looked like banks
to people except that turned out they
weren't - safest banks they weren't
regulated they weren't they didn't have
a safety net they certainly didn't have
insurance and this thing which people
call the shadow banking system or the
parallel banking system was on the eve
of the crisis it was bigger than the
conventional banking system and it's now
imploded it's just basically he
shriveled up and that was what we didn't
understand I mean you know we there were
hints of it but no one I think until the
crisis hit realize just how big this
wasn't and how fragile it was
it's not that easy because these things
are not that that visible so you know
there are a lot of money market floods
people probably have some money market
funds in mind many people have money in
money market funds I guess I have some
in you know I did what is an Ag edward's
money market fund which is now
thankfully insured because the Fed moved
in to rescue it but you know I think
anybody any money market fund was part
of this asset-backed or actually auction
rate securities which is a classic
because that was a three hundred fifty
billion dollar bank in effect that that
wasn't called the bank those were mostly
set up by banks you've heard of they
were set up by Citibank or or in some
cases by the investment banks but
typically they were set up by Citigroup
or or JP Morgan but they were not
guaranteed by that it wasn't part of
their the regular thing and so people
had these things in money in these
institutions these arrangements and
didn't realize what what they were
actually getting into is it's it's a
lack of obvious brand names and this
part of the problem
you